but i'm saying the data indicates that  men aren't that picky because if it was  men had really high standards they  wouldn't swipe right 50 of the time on  dating apps but also also when you look  at it when you look at ethnic cultures  like chinese african or anything like  that it's always the moms telling the  daughters oh you're putting them away  you need to lose weight so it's it's not  the dead it doesn't tend to be the same  sorry but again i said before that the  certain things that we know are  objective truths and those women know  that the objective truth is that men  tend to like slimmer women they tend to  and so if you're going to make yourself  more  of a desirable female for men  then yes they are going to tell you you  need to lose weight can i quickly dial  back to thin privilege just